let's say someone has a great story idea
what do they do next
well there's the thing is there's a lot
of things they can do um
if it's well if it's i get people that
come up to me with story ideas all the
time
and i say well write it you know they
have an idea
and they think that's enough and that's
not enough if you
have an idea and you manage to make it
into a story and then turn that story
into a script
now you have something and then you say
well yeah that my script is so big it's
10 million
budget you know there's nothing we could
do about it well what can you shoot from
it
that isn't going to cost you 10 million
dollars that's what i'm doing right now
you know a script i wrote been writing
for 10 years that i want to get made
um i finally just said i got gotta shoot
something from this
the script's done it is done it's ready
to go i'm not gonna get money to do this
because they're not gonna understand it
unless i get some type of angel donor
no studio is gonna understand what i'm
trying to do here
i'm not quad on you know i'm not him
they're not gonna
take a chance on this project but what
can i do to help them
understand what it is well there's three
scenes i can shoot that cost me very
little money
and that's what i do so that's what i'm
doing right now there are no rules
like now is like the old west in terms
of independent filmmaking
is it harder to get something on the
theater absolutely
but to get something made it is not hard
to get it seen and shown
it's not hard now to get on netflix
that's going to be a little bit harder
absolutely but it's not impossible you
know what i mean it's not a rich man's
game anymore
you're only confined by
the things that you put in front of
yourself you know so i always tell
people like
shoot something from it or write
something smaller
you know don't i think your big idea is
going to be the first thing out i got a
friend right now that
it's gonna be 12 13 years and it's like
is it a great idea yeah it's the time
now yeah
but nobody's going to trust you with a
40 million dollar budget
to do your pro your passion project
essentially
because they're going to ask what have
you been doing for 12 years
you've been having the same thing for 12
years
do something you you should have been
building up to that don't have
one thing you know i don't say be a jack
of all trades i'm saying as a writer
have tears if you're a writer director
have tiers of things that you can do
if it's a three page
[Music]
short that's fine you could tell if you
could tell a story in beginning middle
and in three pages
that's a skill you know and now you have
something put it out there see what
people say about it
um it's it's always never relying on
this kind of like ethereal thing that
something is going to happen
it's always relying on your own two
hands
because then you have no expectations
right you can do it
and you people like it or don't like it
or find the right spot
you don't know there's so many you can
only control what you
what you can do not help not everything
else
you know i couldn't tell you how i was
gonna get my first three films financed
you know i didn't go about it uh the way
that normal people do
you know i took my short films and
packaged them like a dvd you would buy
in a you know at a video store
and i passed them out to all the local
film festivals that rejected those films
and guess what there was a distributor
producer there and he ended up
financing my first three films oh wow so
that's a cool story
you just have to find new ways you know
i'm not a big proponent of crowdfunding
um but if
you know my thing is go get a go get a
job for three months
and save up you know why don't ask
people to
give you money for something that you
don't even know if you're capable of
pulling off
and you you've said earlier that you
feel like the first film
that an indie filmmaker makes whether
it's through crowdfunding
a combination family friends co-workers
that's easy
yes and then subsequent ones
very very tough very tough why is that
well let it
if it's a double-edged sword so let's
say you've crowdfunded your first film
right you got it you're 22 000. 22 000
seems to be the
the magic number that everyone goes
after right so you
crowdfund you do it and everyone comes
to the screening and they're all excited
and they got their button and their
t-shirt or whatever
and then nothing happens okay nothing in
the sense of it didn't go to sundance or
didn't get distribution or
it didn't do anything so you start your
next one right
now you have to make your second film
that a lot of people will be like well i
gave you a hundred dollars last time
to support you i don't have that money
to help you with this second one you're
gonna have to figure that out
you know or you know that
that becomes then it becomes about the
crowdfunding not about the storytelling
you know because the amount of work it
takes just to crowdfund
is unbelievable and it's not something i
enjoy at all
you know and to me it's like if you have
22 000 that's what you're raising
you a percentage of that's going to go
to um
is going to go to the the the
the platform that you're using plus a
percentage of that's going to go to all
the little things that you've promised
people whether they're buttons or coffee
mugs or whatever
and then a lot of people notice you have
to pay a tax on that because it's
considered income
unless you're a non-profit but if you're
making a movie you want to make a profit
so then what do you have left over you
know and then if let's say
you owe your rent the next month i've
seen that happen too many times there
was a two-year period where me and my
wife were donating hundred dollars
to uh projects that were being
crowdfunded
and we did 20 in a two-year period so
about two thousand dollars over two
years
out of those 20 projects one of them was
made
you know so i just stopped and i get
people all the time hey can you help us
out can you help us out i said look man
i wish you well be at your screening
i'll share whatever you wanted me to
share but
i'm not i'm not giving money anymore i
got two kids and a wife and
i want to put them both through call my
two kids through college
you know so i go but i wish you well you
know and then
for sure enough there's like you know
three you hear it every day on social
media
then as soon as the money is raised you
don't hear about the project anymore i'm
like what happened to your project
well rents do that's the problem
with this script that you've been
writing for 10 years or maybe would you
write it for 10 years sorry or did did
it take 10 years for you to get to this
point
it took 10 years for me to get to this
point okay it took me about
three or four years to write it and it's
my 10th script yeah
my 10th screenplay and so when you said
i'm gonna just do
three scenes is that it yeah i'm
shooting three scenes that show the
character
from the womb to a 10 year old to an 18
year old
ah so you're doing it in in sequential
order then oh okay
okay that's was what i was wondering is
how are you determining which scenes to
shoot so you're um i'm showing
his journey in little increments and i'm
hoping the audience is going to go
wow what happened between here and here
what happened between here and there
because in between those scenes i have
an incredible actor a
chicano icon actor that have grown up
watching pepe cerna
and he plays what i'm calling the
chicano chorus and he's
it's uh it's i wrote it in iambic
pentameter
so he's telling this shakespearean story
in between
those vignettes to fill the audience in
the blank
this is very stylized um
and i'm very happy with it uh i have one
one of the vignettes left to shoot but
um
i'm editing it and i'm rewriting that
last vignette
uh because i've been completely happy of
it and they're not taken from the script
the story is but the scripts
are the script only one scene is
actually word for word from the script
i had to modify the other ones to show
some history and
a little bit of that character's journey
how do you know you have a great
protagonist
i don't i don't ever yeah
don't ever um
it's a chance you know with first
writing it and then bringing the right
actor
you know that was something that a lot
of actors take for granted is can they
carry a movie
you know in an independent world like
there are no you know you're looking for
someone you have to go off your instinct
is this guy going to carry this movie
you know and are people going to be
interested in this person
through out the entire hour and a half
that's something i don't take for
take that for granted you know because
if they don't
the movie's done you know and i've been
fortunate that
i've worked with actors that have moved
on to bigger and better things and
that's been a validation
of for me because when i cast them they
weren't sag they didn't have an agent
they didn't
they were diamonds in the rough um so
i'm always my wife says you're every
actor's good luck charm
she's like they always move on to bigger
and better things well that's great
but uh but it's so it's a validation of
my casting process as well
you